en garde ce dimanche 20 novembre bio
quoi peut être accueillis au gymnase
maurice baquet les futures stars
françaises de l'escrim 70 jeunes âgés de
11 à 14 ans ont participé à ce tournoi
départemental baptisée horizon 2024 la
journée qualificative pour les
championnats nationaux avait également
pour but de détecter les pépites de
discipline et de quelques personnes bien
prometteur c'est bien chez les filles
que chez les garçons et pas uniquement
dans le club de guingamp pour sentiments
il ya d'autres clubs du département qui
s'illustre au niveau national
objectif des organisateurs impulser un
nouveau souffle sur cette discipline en
france ce sport plus grand pourvoyeur de
médailles pour les tricolores aux jo
avec 118 médailles reste sur deux
olympiades mitigé avec seulement trois
médailles engrangées en huit ans et pas
forcément aussi de redorer ses pouvoir
briller lors des grandes compétitions et
donc pour ça se prépare
et il faut détecter le plus tôt possible
les personnes capables d'aller loin ce
dimanche matin chaque participant a déjà
à son actif plus de trois ans
d'expérience dans la discipline espère
continuer sa passion au plus haut niveau
c'est un sport de rapidité et ça qui me
plaît et que on joue beaucoup avec son
adversaire
mais que ce soit les contrats des
contraintes les touchent jamais eu tout
absolument tout la concentration la
patience
et en même temps il faut être vraiment
très rapide pour attaquer une passion
qui pourrait les emmener à combattre en
2024 au grand palais à paris si la
france est retenue pour organiser les
jeux un rêve à la pointe de l'épée